[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah on va parler de sexe bien je vois que
j'ai votre attention
qui êtes vous comment est votre corps
comment est ce que vous vous sentez
dedans et qui vous attire
c'est à toutes ces réponses à toutes ces
questions qu'on va essayer de trouver
les réponses ensemble ce soir
bon après je vais pas vous mentir toutes
ces réponses vous les avez en vous mais
bon de nos jours quand on trouve pas des
réponses tout de suite qu'est ce qu'on
fait on va sur internet vous avez la
france j'ai fait les recherches pour
vous alors mais aussi sur internet en
train d'essayer de chercher c'est
répondre justement
et là je tombe sur deux mots dont je ne
comprends pas la signification
ces deux mots c'est bisexuels et
transsexuels alors comme je suis sur un
terrain je vais les regarder la
définition et là je suis confuse je suis
confuse parce que ces deux mots qui sont
différents bah pour moi ils ont même
définition bisexuels attirance envers
des hommes et les femmes pas sexuel
attirance
ouvert tous les genres et là je me suis
posé une question et du coup ça veut
dire qu'il existe plus que de genre
qu'est ce que c'est le genre exactement
maintenant je vais vous poser une
question qui est allé au danemark lever
la main s'il vous plaît
il y en a quelques-uns à haren dans la
petite ville de loos très sympathique et
qu'est-ce qui arrose le musée de la
femme dans personne personne hommage
c'est dommage parce que quand on arrive
au musée de la femme
art au danemark
on tombe sur sa des spectres joli nom de
cette plus près donc on a quatre spectre
pour le sexe le genre l'expression est
l'attraction et chacun de ce spectre va
de l'homme à la femme
maintenant vous demander de prendre une
grande aspiration voilà et de ne plus
penser à ce que éventuellement pourrait
penser le voisin c'est quelque chose de
complètement personnel donc en fait
c'est spectre là on peut se situer
dessus donc évidemment comme ont évolué
à travers le temps l'appareil la
position de ces curseurs va aussi
évoluer en fonction de nous donc on a le
premier spectre le spectre de sexe en
fait la réponse à la question dans quel
corps est-ce que je suis né c'est votre
sexe biologique et c'est sur un spectre
et non juste une boîte hommes ou de
boîtes femme parce que non on ne naît
pas tous soient hommes soient femmes il
ya aussi des intersexe par exemple et
tout ça c'est très bien expliqué
paralyse rigueur dans son thé xx sur le
sexe biologique que je vous invite à
visionner si ça vous intéresse si vous
voulez en savoir un petit peu plus sur
ce sujet on a ensuite le spectre de
genre là je vais vous demander d'oublier
le corps dans lequel vous êtes né et de
vous demander mentalement
ou est ce que parce que 20 à qui est-ce
que vous identifier le plus aux hommes
aux femmes aux deux à aucun des deux
spécifiquement faites vous plaisir c'est
votre truc
ensuite on à l'expression parce qu'une
fois qu'on a notre sexe biologique et
notre identité de genre comment est-ce
qu'on l'expriment au reste du monde donc
ça va être par la façon de nous habiller
la façon de parler de bouger notre corps
et enfin le spectre des attractions qui
vous attire les hommes les femmes les
deux tous les genres possibles et
inimaginables personnel et donc je sais
que c'est peut-être un petit peu
compliqué de comprendre tout comme ça
comment donc je vais vous donner des
exemples de coups parce que vous aimez
gêné bien comme ce sont des spectres
qu'il ya des combinaisons absolument
infinie je montrais un exemple de
combinaisons normal donc je regardais
aller les curseurs noir donc tourner à
ici le laser va marcher
on a ici quelqu'un qui est né dans un
dans un corps d'homme qui se sent hommes
qui s'expriment hommes et qui aime les
femmes
une autre combinaison normal cette fois
regarder les cuisses les curseurs blanc
donc quelqu'un qui est né dans un corps
de femme qui se sent femme qui s'exprime
femmes et qui hier les hommes maintenant
une autre combinaison normal si le
curseur veux bien vous j'y vois là alors
on a quelqu'un qui est né dans un corps
d'homme qui se sent femme qui va
s'exprimer femmes et qui va aimer tous
genres on retrouve ici notre banc
sexuelle de tout à l'heure pour ceux qui
suivent donc je noter ici que pour
sexuelle ça s'adresse juste c'est le
terme juste pour le spectre d'attraction
une autre combinaison normal encore
c'est quelqu'un qui est né intersexe qui
se sont pas forcément d'identité ni
homme ni femme que à l'extérieur du
spectre qui s'exprime plutôt hommes et
qui attire et envers les hommes et les
femmes
le buisson
tout à l'heure c'est qu'ici donc en
résumé on a tous un sexe biologique une
identité de genre une expression et d
attraction pourquoi est ce que je vous
raconte tout ça parce que ça fait deux
ans je fais des recherches là dessus et
qu'avec ce que j'ai découvert
je veux comprend mieux et je me sens
plus à l'aise dans la peau alors je me
suis dit que si je vous expliquais sac
je faisais en sorte que soyez plus à
l'aise dans votre peau et que vous
puissiez mieux vous comprendre
c'était quand même sympa de le partager
j'en profite pour vous remercier de
votre attention depuis le début de ce
fait parce que pour peut-être après je
veux je me trompe peut-être que c'est
qu'une attention polie de la part de
certains peut-être que oui certains se
sentent vraiment pas concernés par ce
sujet c'est un mauvais choix de mots on
est tous concerné par ça mais bon c'est
pas un truc qui les préoccupent
particulièrement sujet tu pas la peine
d'en parler quoi mais peut-être que ça
préoccupe voisins ou votre voisine où
quelqu'un dans cette salle où quelqu'un
dans votre vie pour qui c'est important
donc en fait c'est l'acceptation de soi
mais aussi l'acceptation des autres à
laquelle est rattachée vos propos ça me
fait penser à une phrase que j'aime
particulièrement de pierre desproges et
sur laquelle je vais vous laisser
il s'agit de celle ci l'ouverture
d'esprit n'est pas une frappe de crabes
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]